here now Florida Senator Marco Rubio
senator how are you
he said he's preparing for
they have been ramping up their military
now for over a decade and now they
increase their defense budget in another
7.6 percent and president XI said he's
preparing for war I assume it's against
us is that a bad wrong assumption
well it's not against Belgium or
Luxembourg it's a look I think the
bottom line is we're in a conflict and I
think we have to start talking about it
that way you know we a lot of times most
of people are up here and I don't
remember you know I was very young
obviously at the end of the Cold War but
it's been about 30 years since there was
another superpower on the earth that was
in conflict with the United States and
we are back in that place and we need to
stop pretending like that's not the case
now I hope it's never an armed conflict
but it's a conflict at every level you
can imagine and I think look we have a
couple problems number one the White
House the Biden Administration is filled
with a bunch of traditional you know
conventional political figures that grew
up over the last 20 years talking about
cooperating with China we saw how that
worked out they took all of our jobs
they took all of our factories they got
rich we got poorer their middle class
grew our middle class shrunk name they
make things and uh and and we don't that
that was you know and so but but I think
the other problem we have and you've
alluded to this is these guys in China
they watched TV I mean they watch TV
broadcast of what's happening in America
and I I hate saying this because I don't
want to encourage your enemies but you
turn on the TV and you watch Joe Biden
speak on any topic on any day that does
not Inspire respect or apprehension on
the part of our adversaries they're
probably saying Now's the Time to strike
guys well definitely are doing that and
look at this new alliance that is
emerging I call it a new axis of Evil I
mean you got Russia you got China now
they bring in the Iranians they broke or
deal with Saudi Arabia now they're
brokering another deal with Saudi Arabia
and Syria and they're telling Kevin
McCarthy not to meet with an Allied
leader and then uh what is what are the
consequences for the balloon spying what
are the consequences for taking out an
American drone like like Putin did
there have been no consequences and I
think that's part of the challenge that
we have on our hands here look it goes
beyond these things that just today
today Brazil in our hemisphere largest
country in the Western Hemisphere south
of us cut a trade deal with China
they're going to from now on do trade in
their own currencies get right around
the dollar they're creating a secondary
economy in the world totally independent
of the United States we won't have to
talk about sanctions in five years
because there'll be so many countries
transacting and currencies other than
the dollar that we won't have the
ability to sanction them as we are
sitting here you know focused on some of
these nuttiness that's going on people
that are basically dedicating their
lives in this country to ensuring that
it is legal to mutilate children to do
drag shows in schools they dedicate
their lives to this and we have a a
another superpower that basically wants
to become the world's dominant power at
our expense and these people don't want
to focus on it you know we had a some
person on The View yesterday say that
our criminal justice system is no better
than what China is doing with its
genocide of uyghur Muslims so we better
wake up or we're going to live in a very
different world than the one we've been
used to and it's going to happen we have
military installations now that have
drag queen shows you know that I played
that earlier yeah but I mean it's part
of the I don't know if you saw this poll
yesterday I don't put a lot of stock
into the polls but if you think about
all of the values that make you a strong
Society family children's patriotism all
of that is diminished the only thing
that matters now the thing that has gone
up is people care about money and I'm
not saying that doesn't matter but China
knows it and they use it against us and
they know that in America they believe
one day there are enough people to
pressure their politicians because they
care more about buying cheap shirts off
an app from China than they do about
standing up for their own country at
some point we need to figure out that we
are Americans someone needs to stand up
for this country we don't no one will
and that the world is a better place
because of America and it'll be a worse
place if America declines Senator Marco
Rubio thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else